Since the original "The Fast and the Furious"
in 2001, each film in the franchise has added
more names onto the roster. With two decades
worth of Fast films and more on the way, that's
a lot of faces and backstories to remember. So
we've recapped every main character's story,
including where they started, where they are now,
and any notable stops they've made along the way.
When we meet Dominic Toretto in "The Fast and the
Furious," he's helping his sister, Mia run their
family's small L.A. market, while also running
an operation stealing electronics off moving
18-wheelers and participating in illegal street
races. Dom was once incarcerated for assaulting
the man he blamed for causing the accident that
killed his father. However, that wasn't enough
to steer him away from crime, which eventually
led to him going on the run to avoid arrest.
Dom's been with his girlfriend, Letty, since
they were teenagers. They eventually marry
in the fourth film, although their wedding
isn't revealed until the seventh. In between,
when Dom's forced to flee justice again, he learns
Letty's been killed. After taking time to grieve,
he dates Elena Neves, fathering a child with
her, although he doesn't learn about his son's
existence until months after he's born. While
Elena's pregnant, he learns Letty's alive but
suffering from amnesia. Elena steps aside
so they can be together. Eventually,
Letty regains her memories,
and, following Elena's death,
Letty and Dom raise his son together,
whom Dom names after his best friend.
"Everyone, meet Brian."
After many films spent evading justice,
Dom's taste for crime increases over the course
of the series, although he tends to target greedy
corporations and corrupt crime lords. But
the most valuable thing to him is family,
specifically the crew he's assembled to
help him pull off his various schemes.
"The most important thing in life will always be
the people in this room. Right here, right now."
In "Fast and Furious 6," Dom and his
crew partner with the government to
bring down various terrorists, earning
them full pardons for their past crimes.
Introduced in "The Fast and the Furious,"
undercover LAPD officer Brian O'Conner
initially ingratiates himself with Dom under
false pretenses. His goal is to earn Dom's
trust so that he can catch him and his crew
in the act and arrest them all. But gradually,
his friendship with Dom turns genuine, and
Brian ultimately chooses Dom over his career.
Brian goes underground but is found by the FBI,
who offer him a deal: bring down drug lord Carter
Verone and get pardoned. Brian agrees, and joins
the FBI. Later, he sends Letty undercover with
cartel leader Arturo Braga, but later learns
she's been killed. To track down her killer,
he reunites with Dom, as well as Dom's sister,
Mia, whom Brian briefly dated years before.
When Dom kills Letty's supposed murderer and
earns himself a lifelong prison sentence,
Brian ditches his career again
to partner with Mia and free him.
Later, when Mia tells Brian she's pregnant, Brian
and Dom decide to pull off one last heist that'll
allow them to drop off the grid and live in peace.
But Brian is pulled back to crime twice more
after that — once, when Dom learns that Letty's
alive, and again when their crew is targeted by
a terrorist. Finally, with a second baby on the
way, Brian decides to step away from the fast,
furious lifestyle for good, settling
down with Mia and his growing family.
Off-screen, Brian was written out of the
franchise because of Paul Walker's sudden
death during production of "Furious 7." While
Mia can still return as part of the crew,
Brian's story is complete, with his character
last seen driving off happily into the sunset.
Letty Ortiz has long been
Dom's partner in everything,
sticking by him even when Dom keeps leaving
her behind. After he goes on the run at the
end of "The Fast and the Furious," Letty
spends several years tracking him down,
eventually finding him in the Dominican
Republic. Picking up where they left off,
the couple wastes no time in secretly marrying
before pulling their biggest heist yet. But
when the plan goes sideways, Dom goes on the
run, once again leaving Letty on her own.
Letty brokers a deal with Brian:
She'll go undercover to help bring down
Braga in exchange for Dom's pardon.
But when she uncovers a plot to kill her,
she tries to flee, only to be left for dead.
Eventually Letty awakens in the hospital with
amnesia, and is taken in by criminal Owen Shaw.
Letty works for years as part of Shaw's
crew, with no memory of her former life,
but switches sides when she encounters Dom and
he wins her trust. The two date for a while,
but Letty breaks up with him, because she doesn't
think they should be together while she still
lacks her memories. However, she regains
them when Dom's nearly killed, and the two
finally take their long-overdue honeymoon.
Even when Dom appears to betray the team after
being blackmailed, Letty never loses faith, and
welcomes him back into the family with open arms.
"You know I never left you, Letty."
"I know."
"And you know I never will."
Mia Toretto resisted her brother's criminal
endeavors for a long time, but she's
eventually pulled in when Dom is sentenced
to prison and she helps Brian break him out.
After that, Mia sticks with Brian as they travel
internationally and pull off daring heists.
When they're double-crossed by a crime lord named
Reyes, Brian and Dom believe they'll need to split
up to avoid being caught. Mia disagrees, revealing
she's pregnant. The trio instead decide to recruit
a crew to steal $100 million of Reyes' money so
that they can go underground and live in peace.
Once the heist is complete, Mia and Brian
settle down in the Canary Islands. There,
she gives birth to their son, Jack. Afterward,
she agrees that Brian should help Dom
find Letty while she stays with Jack,
but she gets kidnapped by Owen Shaw.
After being freed, just as Mia realizes she's
expecting their second child, their house blows
up. Brian joins Dom for one final mission,
and once their family is finally safe again,
Mia and Brian retire for good. However,
Mia will be rejoining the action — this
time without Brian — when her estranged
older brother Jakob shows up in "F9."
Roman Pearce started stealing cars at a young
age. But when his friend Brian O'Conner joined
the LAPD, Roman grew resentful, especially when
Brian did nothing to help when Roman was arrested.
The two reconnect in "2 Fast 2 Furious," when
Brian recruits Roman to help in an investigation,
requiring them to go undercover. In return,
the FBI promises them both a pardon. They
complete their mission and clear their names,
and recover a large amount of stolen money.
Unbeknownst to the FBI, though, Roman also sets
aside a generous portion of the cash for himself.
Roman re-enters the picture in "Fast Five,"
when Brian and Dom need someone on their team
who can talk his way out of any situation.
After pocketing $11 million from that heist,
Roman lives lavishly, buying expensive cars
and a private jet, but still rejoins the crew
whenever he's needed. He helps Dom find Letty and
foil both Shaw brothers, and sticks around after
Brian retires. When Dom seems to betray the crew
while being blackmailed by Cipher, Roman is part
of the group that works to stop him, and is quick
to welcome him back once the truth is revealed.
Introduced in "2 Fast 2 Furious," super-mechanic
Tej meets Brian O'Conner while Brian is living
in Miami, and the two become friends
through the street racing scene. Later,
Tej assists Brian and Roman in
their undercover FBI assignment.
Brian brings Tej back in for the heist in
"Fast Five," using his tech skills to hack
into Reyes' advanced security system. Tej
also becomes close to Roman, although the
two never miss an opportunity to get under each
other's skin. From "Fast Five" on, Tej works
as an integral part of the crew, working as the
team's mechanic, hacker, and occasional driver.
Only appearing in "2 Fast 2 Furious," Suki is a
street racer with a mostly female crew of her own.
She is friends with Brian and Tej, and proves
a valuable asset when Roman and Brian need help
throwing the police off their scent. While
Tej drives Brian's car, Suki drives Roman's,
leading the police on a wild goose
chase away from their actual targets.
A significant character in "2 Fast 2 Furious,"
Monica Fuentes is an undercover U.S. Customs
agent who's working to expose Miami drug lord
Carter Verone. When Brian and Roman are also
embedded in the operation, Monica blows her cover
to pass Brian important information. Realizing
Monica's betrayal, Verone takes her hostage
aboard his boat, but Brian and Roman distract
him long enough for Monica to take advantage of
the situation. She holds Verone at gunpoint until
she's able to arrest him. Several years later,
she alerts Hobbs that Letty is still alive.
Ex-Mossad agent Gisele is introduced as an
employee of Arturo Braga in the fourth film.
However, Gisele warns Dom that Braga
plots to kill his drivers. Later,
Dom saves Gisele's life, then recruits Gisele in
"Fast Five" as an official member of his crew.
"I think I'm in love."
After becoming a couple in "Fast Five," Gisele
and Han are in Hong Kong together when they
receive Dom's call to come help stop Shaw
and save Letty in the sixth film. Tragically,
toward the end of the film, Gisele is hanging
off the top of a speeding car when she sees one
of Shaw's henchmen preparing to kill Han. Making
a split-second call, Gisele releases her grip on
Han's hand in order to kill his attacker,
saving his life as she falls to her death.
Han got his start in director Justin Lin's
earlier film, "Better Luck Tomorrow."
In high school, Han was part of an
organized cheating operation that spun
out of control and eventually resulted in a
murder. Following the events of that film, Han
left to travel the world. He met Dom in Mexico,
and occasionally helped with various missions.
Han's first appearance is in the third film,
but chronologically, his first mission is
in the fourth released film in the franchise,
which serves as a prequel to the third. Quiet,
observant, and adaptable, Han helps with Dom's
heists in the fourth, fifth, and sixth movies,
during which he also falls in love with
fellow crew member Gisele. The two dream
of globe-trotting and growing old together, but
those plans are dashed when Gisele sacrifices
herself to save Han while working to take down
Owen Shaw. Grieving, Han heads to Tokyo, where
he befriends a group of local street racers and
takes American teen Sean Boswell under his wing.
Han also begins stealing from the Yakuza,
eventually finding himself in a high-speed
chase once his crimes are discovered. The chase
ends in a horrific crash, but it turns out to be
no accident — Han was targeted by Owen's brother,
Deckard Shaw. It appears Han dies in the crash,
but "F9" reveals that, somehow, Han actually
survived and will rejoin Dom's crew.
The youngest protagonist in the franchise, Sean
Boswell appears in "The Fast and the Furious:
Tokyo Drift" as an Alabama teen with
a penchant for reckless driving.
After being sent to Tokyo to live with his
father, Sean quickly falls in with the city's
street racing scene. But the Japanese racers
all know how to "drift" — maneuvering around
tight corners via controlled skids — a skill
which Sean is initially unable to master.
Han takes Sean under his wing and teaches
him how to drift. Sean also flirts with a
girl that turns out to be the girlfriend of
Takashi, the local Drift King and the nephew
of a Yakuza member. After Han's apparently
killed while being pursued by the Yakuza,
Sean challenges Takashi to a race, with
the loser agreeing to leave Tokyo for good.
Thanks to Han's teaching, Sean beats
Takashi, and is crowned the new Drift King.
Afterward, he meets Dom while Dom is
in Tokyo investigating Han's death.
An American army brat, Twinkie
eventually landed in Tokyo,
selling stolen goods out of Han's garage.
He met Sean Boswell in high school,
and they become friends after they
bond over Twinkie's unique car.
Through Twinkie, Sean is introduced to
Han and the Tokyo street racing crowd.
And when Sean finds himself on the wrong
side of the Yakuza after Han's death,
Twinkie even gives him money to pay off his debts.
The two remain friends at the end of the movie,
with Twinkie serving as the second
in command to the new Drift King.
Originally serving as a secondary antagonist in
"Fast Five," Luke Hobbs enters the picture as a
Diplomatic Security Service agent tasked
with tracking down the crew. However,
after finally getting the upper hand and arresting
Dom, Brian, and several members of their crew,
Hobbs' caravan is ambushed. When Dom, Brian,
and their friend Vince save Hobbs' life,
he decides to join them to get revenge. After the
mission is complete, Hobbs returns to the DSS,
where he learns Letty Ortiz is alive. Hobbs passes
this intel to Dom, and after Dom's crew assists
in tracking Letty down and capturing Owen Shaw,
Hobbs is able to negotiate pardons for everyone.
Hobbs is later injured when Deckard Shaw breaks
into the DSS in search of information on the crew,
but still helps bring Shaw to justice. Later, when
Hobbs is tasked with an off-the-books mission,
he calls on Dom and his crew to help him.
But Dom's double-cross for Cipher winds up
sending Hobbs to prison. He breaks out
and helps the team stop Cipher. Later,
Hobbs is tasked by the CIA with teaming up with
Deckard Shaw to recover a dangerous bioweapon,
which leads to him reconnecting
with his estranged family in Samoa.
We meet Elena in "Fast Five," when
she's recruited by Hobbs to assist
in his investigation. But when
she comes face to face with Dom,
she opts not to shoot him when she has the
chance. In turn, Dom saves her from Reyes' men,
making Elena question whether he could really
be guilty of the crimes he's accused of.
After Dom and Brian save her life again, Elena
leaves her law enforcement career to go on the
run with Dom. The two begin a relationship
on the Canary Islands, where she also grows
close to Brian and Mia. But when Dom learns
Letty's alive, Elena urges him to find her.
Elena stays behind to protect Mia and baby Jack,
getting Jack to safety when Mia's kidnapped. After
Dom finds Letty, Elena steps aside — not
revealing she's pregnant with Dom's child.
Eventually, after joining the DSS with Hobbs,
Elena gives birth in secret. Shortly after,
she and her infant son are kidnapped by
Cipher to use as leverage against Dom.
Elena tells Dom she's given the baby a middle
name — Marcos — but she wanted Dom to choose
his first name. Elena is soon executed by
Cipher as punishment for Dom's insubordination.
We meet Vince in "The Fast and the Furious"
as a loyal member of Dom's crew who
instantly distrusts Brian. Part of Vince's
issue with Brian is Mia's attraction to him,
since Vince wants her attention for himself.
When the crew's heist goes drastically
wrong at the end of the first film,
Vince is seriously injured, prompting Brian to
blow his cover to get Vince medical attention.
At some point after his recovery, Vince goes
on the run, winding up in Rio de Janeiro, where
he meets the woman who'd eventually become his
wife and mother of his son. After spending years
resenting Brian, Vince ultimately forgives him
when he returns in "Fast Five." He offers shelter
to Brian and Mia and rejoins the crew. Tragically,
he's killed by Reyes' men when they attack Hobbs,
so Dom gives Vince's portion of the $100
million heist to Vince's wife and son.
Owen Sha16_w turned mercenary after
being dishonorably discharged from the
military. He became an associate of Arturo
Braga, which is how he met Letty Ortiz,
intending to finish her off after Braga's
initial attempt to kill her failed.
But instead he recruited Letty
as part of his criminal crew.
After Braga's arrest, Shaw begins stealing
components to build an advanced weapon of
mass destruction, which he intends to
sell off to the highest bidder. He acts
ruthlessly, willingly sacrificing members of
his crew and kidnapping Mia to use as leverage
to secure his freedom. He's ultimately stopped
by Dom and is grievously injured in the process.
After being hospitalized for
an extended period of time,
Owen is transferred to a secret location.
While being blackmailed by Cipher,
Dom makes a deal with Shaw's mother to find
him in exchange for her family's assistance,
to which she agrees. Owen, then, is instrumental
in helping rescue Dom's baby from Cipher.
Introduced in "Fast & Furious 6" as a
DSS agent and associate of Luke Hobbs,
Riley Hicks is an ex-soldier with an impressive
record. She works alongside Hobbs to track down
Owen Shaw and his team, and is helpful in both
combat and extracting information from informants.
However, after Dom's group helps Hobbs arrest
Shaw, Riley reveals she's been a double agent
the whole time, and is romantically involved with
Shaw. From that point on, Riley is openly a part
of Shaw's crew, and proves willing to kill for him
in cold blood. Riley is ultimately killed by Letty
when Letty shoots her with a harpoon gun, causing
her to fall from Shaw's plane to her death.
Although Brian and Dom spent most of "Fast &
Furious" working for the drug lord known as Braga,
it turns out the man they thought was Braga
was actually a decoy. The real Braga was his
second-in-command, who'd gone by the name Ramon
Campos. Those closest to him knew about the
deception, but everyone else bought into the lie,
helping the real cartel leader avoid detection.
For a while, this helps him fly
under Brian and Dom's radar. However,
they're eventually able to apprehend him in
Mexico, and he's sentenced to life in prison.
At some point prior to this, though, he formed
an alliance with Owen Shaw, who helped influence
Braga's operation, and whom Braga hired
to kill Letty. While Braga's in prison,
Brian poses as a prisoner to get close to
him in order to find out more information
about what happened to Letty. Braga tells
him everything before attempting to kill him,
but Brian manages to get the upper hand,
stabbing Braga in the leg in the process.
Leo and Santos are friends of Dom's from his
time in the Dominican Republic. The pair are
instrumental in helping Dom plan and execute the
fuel heist at the beginning of the fourth film,
and reappear at the end of the film to
help Brian and Mia break Dom out of prison.
After receiving their cut of their
multimillion-dollar score at the end
of "Fast Five," Santos and Leo head to a casino,
where they wager all their money playing roulette.
We never learn who wins or loses, but they show
up again later in "The Fate of the Furious"
as part of Dom's plan to fake Deckard's
death, proving they still have Dom's trust.
Introduced in the fourth film, F.B.I. agent
Michael Stasiak initially gets along with Brian,
but the two butt heads when Stasiak
brings Mia in for questioning. After
Brian tricks him into letting her go, Stasiak
is suspicious of Brian's loyalties. He winds
up second-guessing him at a critical juncture
that puts their undercover operation at risk.
However, Stasiak still has a good
enough impression of Brian to help
him sneak back into the U.S. in "Fast
& Furious 6." He then gives Brian an
alias and embeds him in the prison where
Braga's being kept so Brian can question him.
First introduced21 in "Furious 7," Ramsey's
an accomplished hacker who catches the crew's
attention after she invents a device called
the God's Eye, which can be used to track
down anyone on the planet. Realizing how
dangerous the God's Eye can be, Ramsey sends
it to a friend to keep safe, but she's then
kidnapped by a mercenary seeking the device.
Knowing Deckard Shaw has targeted Dom's crew, the
government strikes a bargain: If Dom retrieves
Ramsey and the God's Eye, he can use it to
track down Shaw. After the crew rescues Ramsey,
she helps them track down the God's Eye and defeat
Shaw. She eventually joins Dom's crew permanently.
Owen's brother Deckard first appears at the
end of "Fast & Furious 6," tracking down
and presumably killing Han in Tokyo. A
former clandestine military operative
and MI6 agent turned mercenary, Deckard uses
his skills to break into the DSS offices
and steal information on Dom's team. While
he's in Tokyo, he also mails a bomb to Dom's
childhood home, where Mia and Brian are living,
and detonates it while on the phone with Dom.
Deckard continues his attempts to hunt and kill
the crew, but he's ultimately thwarted by Dom
and taken into CIA custody. Hobbs is later put
into the cell opposite him, and the two waste no
time in annoying each other. But before long, the
pair escape during a prison riot, initiated by Mr.
Nobody, a covert government agent. Reluctantly,
Deckard agrees to work with Dom's crew to stop
Cipher, since he also blames her for Owen's fate.
After helping them track down Dom and Cipher,
it appears Deckard is killed by Dom, but that's
revealed to be a ruse facilitated by his mother.
With Owen, Deckard breaks onto
Cipher's plane and rescues Dom's son,
whom he returns safely to Dom. Later, Deckard's
recruited by the CIA to assist Hobbs — to their
mutual irritation — in recovering a bioweapon
possessed by Deckard's sister, Hattie.
Although Cipher isn't introduced
until "The Fate of the Furious,"
she's been pulling strings behind the scenes
for quite some time. She hired Owen Shaw to
steal the components he was assembling in "Fast
& Furious 6," and was the mastermind behind the
plan to steal the God's Eye in "Furious 7."
It's even implied she has ties to Braga.
In the eighth movie, Cipher kidnaps Elena and
her son to use as leverage to manipulate Dom,
which works for a while. However, while Cipher
knows that Dom's loyalty lies with his family,
she underestimates how far
he'll go to keep them safe,
enabling him to eventually
break free of her control.
Motivated by power, Cipher's
goal is to start a nuclear war.
Even though her plans are thwarted
by the end of the eighth movie,
she manages to escape, and will be
returning to collect her revenge in F9.
No one knows Mr. Nobody's real name,
or even which government organization
he works for. All we know is that he's a
covert agent who shows up in "Furious 7"
offering Dom the chance to track down
Deckard Shaw in exchange for his assistance.
Describing himself as a "shadow," Mr. Nobody has
abundant resources and technology at his disposal,
and is untethered by official
policies and procedures.
Mr. Nobody shows up again in "The Fate
of the Furious," staging a prison riot
to free Hobbs and Shaw so that they can
help Dom's crew track down their leader.
Meanwhile, Little Nobody shows up as Mr.
Nobody's protégé in "The Fate of the Furious."
"So then who's he?"
"Him? He's nothing. He's like less than me."
While not on the level of most of Dom's
crew, Little Nobody still participates in
the high-speed effort to stop Cipher
from launching a nuclear submarine.
We first meet Shaw family25_ matriarch Magdalene
in "The Fate of the Furious," when Dom sneaks
away from Cipher long enough to ask her for
help. Dom offers Queenie a deal — in exchange
for her help rescuing his infant son, he will
give her the location of her incarcerated son,
Owen. The trade is acceptable to Magdalene,
who, like Dom, values family above all else.
Sometime later, Queenie goes to
prison, although we never learn why.
But at the end of "Hobbs and Shaw," it's implied
that she's getting ready to break herself out,
thanks to a nail file hidden in a cake
delivered to her by Deckard and Hattie.
We don't know much about Jakob, who'll debut in
"F9." But what we do know indicates he'll be very
different from the other Toretto siblings. Dom and
Mia have never mentioned Jakob, and maybe there's
a good reason for that. The ninth "Fast and the
Furious" film will see Jakob teaming with Cipher
to take down his big brother, which may prove
to be the biggest challenge Dom has ever faced.
Jakob is a skilled assassin and, of course,
an excellent precision driver. We'll
learn what happened to set the Toretto
siblings at one another's throats when
"F9" finally speeds into theaters.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the
Fast and the Furious are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.